اجراءات عده اتخذتها وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه بالتشاوري مع الرئيس جو بايدن
ومع البنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي لتجنب
تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي ولتمكين
المودعين من الحصول على اموالهم
اكرر لا خسائر سيتحملها دافع وضرائب من
اهم ما اكد عليه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايد
ن هو ان جميع اموال المودعين ودافع
الضرائب في البنوك مؤمنه ويمكن الحصول
عليها من دون عائق وطلب من الامريكيين
الثقه في النظام المصرفي فقبل هذه الازمه
كانت الحكومه الفيدراليه تضمن من خلال
المؤسسه الفيدراليه للتامين على الودائع
الودائع التي لا تزيد قيمتها عن 250 الف
دولار
قاعده 250 الف دولار ستستمر ولن تتراجع
الحكومه عنها السبب الوحيد لتعليقها
للبنكين منع العدو الماليه لكن الحكومه
ستغير بعض اللوائح في المستقبل لمحاوله
الحد من اي خطر معنوي ربما يكون قد تسببوا
فيه عبر اقتراح ان الحكومه ستتدخل دائما
لانقاذ المودعين
لكن الوضع بالنسبه للمستثمرين الذين
يخاطرون بودائع امريكيين مختلف وفق بايدن
لانهم لن يحظوا باي حمايه فيما تعهد
بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن ازمه البنوك معتبرا
ان لا احد فوق القانون
سيتم طرد اداره هذه البنوك اذا تم
الاستيلاء على البنك من قبل المؤسسه
الفيدراليه للتامين على الودائع فيجب على
الاشخاص الذين يديرون البنك الا يعملوا
هناك بعد الان
بيضا وعد بان الاجراءات لحمايه المودعين
ولعدم تكرار اخفاقات البنوك ستستمر الى ان
تنتهي ازمه مصرفي سيليكون فالي
فيما سيطلب من الكونجرس تجديد القوانين
المتعلقه بالبنوك حسين الطوض العربيه
واشنطن